[Applause]
who is that chat i brought little kitty
here for you i thought maybe we were
gonna see millie but i hear she's having
a moment
millie does not like the spotlight at
all she doesn't like the camera if she
sees me coming towards her with my phone
or something she leaves the room
well this is um little kitty and i just
rescued her
so
it's
and she's a frisky one but i brought her
in honor of millie
and
congratulations on your extremely
exciting engagement
oh flash of the ring let's see it may i
see it
yeah it's it's it's a beaut it's well
you know i mean it's
it's great it's the best thing that's
ever happened to me and um he's a sweet
baby angel and he's a
that that photo really looks like he has
a girl hand but that's my hand don't
worry about it
the way that you love him
is so sweet and romantic i feel like i
get the love vibes through
the way that you share
your love for him like there's a such an
adoration and appreciation
and i i feel that's so important in
relationships i love the way you love
him
well i'm 35 so i waited a very very you
know
good chunk of time to get married and i
i'm so glad i waited till i found the
right person it's really hard everybody
goes through you know this nightmarish
time of life looking for that person or
not whatever floats your boat but i'm i
feel very lucky and um
he's the best
may i ask about your engagement like
i remember when you announced it and i
was so excited
what was it like
we had a special moment that makes me
believe in
magic
we were doing kissing
um
and we had like a shared feeling um
i felt this intense
feel you know this thing that i was like
this is the this is my person this is it
i can't live without him this is
this is the man i'm supposed to be with
and we looked at each other and we both
proposed at the same time
[Applause]
um
no knee down i don't even remember what
happened after that we just we were like
should we get married and
we're like yes and i just burst into
tears it was like i never thought i i
had it in me you know because i'm a kind
of a toughy
um but i did i
wept happy tears i felt this sense of
relief that i've
i've done it like i made it through the
wilderness and i found this incredible
person and yeah no one believes me but i
assure you that's what happened oh i
believe it
you went from a tuffy to a softie
yes
i love it
you deserve it so much and like i've
seen you do little makeovers um does he
like being made over
yes he's a very patient person um i
don't know if if this audience has had
the unfortunate pleasure to watch this
makeover i did on him uh on instagram i
did a bridal makeup tutorial but instead
of me doing it it's him yes
yes
your eye makeup on him is so good
you know i should have glued on the
false lashes but it that was a bridge
too far i want to ask you about cutting
bangs um
i love how you just go for it and bust
out the full
do-it-yourself diy bangs did you like it
were you into rocking it or were you
like god grow out as soon as possible
huge mistake i don't recommend it
don't do it look at how bad that looks
it looks so bad i mean
you could never look bad no i mean it
was choppy it was bad it would remember
we've been in the pandemic so i was like
i need a change i have i'm so sick of
looking at myself i need something to be
different i watched a bunch of tutorials
and i just chopped and it looked so bad
and to be honest with you i have like a
forehead vein that i focus on that i was
just trying to cover up
and it did work for that
but fashion wise and like something
about my face shape i just looked like
my own grandfather
well your grandfather's hot then
[Music]